(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Acabamos de estudar o que acontece quando o
imóvel não é arrematado em primeiro e em
segundo leilão ex-credencial.
A gente viu, então, que o credor vai
ficar livre para vender o imóvel da forma
e pelo valor que ele quiser.
Uma das formas que os bancos costumam escolher
é colocar esse imóvel em um terceiro leilão
ex-credencial com o valor que o próprio
banco definir.
Não existe mais nada na lei ali estipulando
o valor mínimo para esse terceiro leilão ex
-credencial.
Nesse momento, surge a possibilidade do banco escolher
realizar um terceiro leilão ex-credencial com a
chamada venda condicional.
O que significa essa venda condicional?
O banco vai internamente escolher qual é o
valor que ele acha ok para vender determinado
imóvel e vai pedir para que um leiloeiro
realize um terceiro leilão com uma venda condicional.
Essa venda condicional vai começar com um lance
mínimo abaixo do que o banco de fato
espera receber por aquele imóvel.
Colocar aqui em termos concretos.
Vamos supor que um banco realizou o primeiro
e o segundo leilão ex-credencial de um
apartamento e ninguém arrematou.
Internamente, o banco chegou à conclusão que o
valor de R$ 150 mil, por exemplo,
é ok para vender aquele apartamento.
Ele vai falar para o leiloeiro realizar aquele
terceiro leilão, mas ele quer um terceiro leilão
com uma venda condicional.
Ele vai falar para o leiloeiro, olha, eu
espero receber aqui por esse imóvel R$
150 mil, mas a partir de R$
100 mil eu estou aberto para receber propostas.
Então, o leiloeiro vai colocar lá como lance
mínimo R$ 100 mil, mas vai deixar
bem claro que aquela ali é uma venda
condicional que vai precisar da aprovação do credor
que determinou que aquele leilão acontecesse.
Então, vamos supor que você vai participar desse
leilão.
Esse leilão não vai ter concorrência nenhuma e
você vai arrematar ali por, de fato, R
$ 100 mil.
Você ganhou aquele leilão, mas de fato você
não levou aquele imóvel ainda.
A sua proposta vai ser encaminhada ao credor
que determinou que aquele leilão acontecesse e ele
vai poder aceitar a sua proposta, recusar a
sua proposta ou até fazer uma contraproposta.
No momento que existir uma contraproposta, você como
arrematante não está obrigado a aceitar.
Você estaria vinculado a, de fato, o lance
que você ofereceu, R$ 100 mil aqui
no nosso exemplo.
Se o banco vier com uma contraproposta de
R$ 120 mil, você não precisa aceitar.
Você pode recusar e falar, olha, nesses termos
eu não tenho interesse em prosseguir com o
negócio e você está automaticamente liberado ali daquele
lance que você ofertou.
Então, a consequência de ser um leilão extrajudicial
com uma venda condicional vai ser essa.
Você vai ganhar o leilão, mas a sua
proposta vai precisar ser aceita pelo credor que
determinou aquele leilão.
Atenção, isso só pode existir em terceiro leilão,
porque em primeiro e segundo leilão extrajudicial, o
credor está vinculado a vender o imóvel pelos
preços mínimos determinados em lei.
A gente já estudou aqui nesses módulos quais
são esses preços mínimos, mas vou recapitular só
para ficar mais claro.
No primeiro leilão extrajudicial, o lance mínimo deve
ser igual ao valor que o próprio contrato
de alienação fiduciária estipulou para o imóvel ou
ao valor venal, o que for maior.
Em segundo leilão extrajudicial, o lance mínimo vai
ser igual ao valor da dívida a mais
em cargos.
Não tem como o credor fugir desses valores
mínimos em primeiro e segundo leilão, porque esses
valores são definidos em lei.
Então, essa possibilidade de venda condicional só existe
pós leilão extrajudicial obrigatório por lei, pós realização
do primeiro leilão e pós realização do segundo
leilão, quando o credor, de fato, vai ficar
livre para vender o imóvel da forma e
pelo valor que quiser.
Então, em um terceiro leilão, quando o credor
já está livre para vender da forma e
valor que quiser, existe essa possibilidade de venda
condicional.
Você precisa saber que quando for lá uma
venda condicional, e essa disposição vai constar no
edital daquele terceiro leilão, e os próprios leiloeiros
costumam colocar abaixo do preço mínimo que vai
ser uma venda condicional e vai ser necessária
a aprovação do vendedor para que o seu
lance se concretize.
Então, você precisa saber que essa vai ser
a consequência.
O credor pode aceitar o seu lance, pode
recusar o seu lance, ou o mais comum
é que o credor realize uma contraproposta e
tente ver se a pessoa ainda tem interesse
naquela contraproposta.
Nesse momento, você pode recusar e falar que
não tem interesse e você não estará mais
vinculado àquele lance que você ofertou.
Quem tem se utilizado muito desse mecanismo de
venda condicional em um terceiro leilão é o
Banco Santander.
Então, é mais comum que a gente encontre
isso em um terceiro leilão do Santander, essa
previsão de venda condicional, e a consequência vai
ser essa.
Você vai precisar da aprovação do Santander para,
de fato, comprar aquele imóvel ali pelo lance
que você ofertou e o Santander pode recusar
ou pode fazer uma contraproposta para você aceitar
ou não.
Então, fique ligado que essa possibilidade de venda
condicional existe quando for um terceiro leilão extrajudicial.